International finance is on the precipice.
The World Bank says the global economy is perilously close to falling into recession.
War in Ukraine and the continuing effects of the pandemic...
…mean it has significantly downgraded its expectations for this year.
The global economy is projected to grow by just 1.7 percent in 2023.
The slowest growth for over three decades.
2024 isn't looking much better.
Franziska Ohnsorge from the World Bank told us that more developed nations...
…are on course for a particularly bad year.
By our forecast, slowdowns in advanced economy growth...
…are steeper than in emerging markets and developing economy growth.
In advanced economy, the policy tightening that's currently underway...
...is sharply weighing on growth.
It is much necessary, much needed...
…because inflation has turned out to be much higher for much longer...
…than we had anticipated in even just six months ago.
Six months ago we expected a consensus forecast.
Expected inflation in advanced economies in 2023...
...to be not that far off inflation targets of 2%.
At this point, inflation is expected to be around 5%, double that.
So, of course, central banks are tightening policy.
Have to tighten policy more than anticipated.
And that is weighing on growth.